christians around the world have been
celebrating easter under the shadow of
the pandemic
for the second year running pope francis
has given his traditional blessing from
saint peter's basilica in rome
he stressed the importance of vaccines
and urged rich countries to ensure
supplies are fairly distributed to their
poorer neighbors
a blessing for the faithful
pope francis addressed just a small
crowd compared to the usual
tens of thousands on easter sunday but
his message was one for the world
international i urge the entire
international community
in a spirit of global responsibility
to commit to overcoming delays in the
distribution of vaccines
and to facilitate their distribution
the catholic leader focused his message
on the world's most vulnerable
including those suffering from the
coronavirus pandemic
and he called for an end to armed
conflicts around the globe like that in
syria
where many also gathered to mark one of
the most important christian holidays of
the year
just as christ suffered this week the
holy week for christians
for the salvation of humanity we are
also suffering every day
with the long war that came to us with
the coronavirus pandemic
the economic
[Music]
they were among the millions across the
world who found ways to celebrate
despite the covert 19 restrictions
in jerusalem however this year's
worshippers were allowed to participate
in mars at the holy sepulchre
considered the holiest place in
christianity but even there the pandemic
was front of mind
[Music]
i think about my family for example in
brazil
they are in home and they cannot see the
light
be here meeting jerusalem inside the
church in this moment
it's totally
[Music]
like the pope in rome they too speak of
hope
amid the pandemic
now for some of the latest developments
in the pandemic
germany's health minister is considering
lifting restrictions for fully
vaccinated people
that's according to the bid newspaper a
study shows they are unlikely to spread
the virus britain is planning trials of
vaccine
passports for sporting events and
nightclubs
and turkey has recorded a number of new
cases
infections have surged since the
government eased restrictions
a month ago